Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Ferron cousins from Ring of Fire sitting in
for David Pakman. And if you would like even
more from me, you can follow me on Twitter,
Instagram, Facebook and TikTok. On all of those
platforms. I'm at fair and balanced. You can also
follow my YouTube channels. YouTube.com
slash. Fair and balanced. And of course,
the big one. YouTube.com slash. The Ring of Fire.
Let's talk about some of the problems facing
Donald Trump's lawyers. And no, I'm not talking
about all the issues with Joe Tacopina, the
issues that have come up with Jim Trusty,
the sanctions that Elina Harbor was hit with. No,
I'm actually going old school with Trump lawyers.
Jenna Ellis, the former Trump lawyer who,
of course, worked on efforts to overturn the
2020 election for which she was also punished in
Colorado. This week, she posted some screenshots
of messages that she has received in messages
that she has seen online from angry MAGA fans
who are angry at her about something that,
according to Jenna, isn't even happening.
These attacks are disgustingly sexist and crude,
but I'm going to read a couple of them here.
These again, these are the ones that she posted.
First one, of course, was from Laura Loomer,
who, according to Raw Story, mocked her for
being, quote, disowned by Trumpworld and trying to
ingratiate herself with Ron DeSantis, his campaign
by offering herself up as, quote, sloppy seconds.
Trump supporter Preston Porras took a similar
line of attack and accused her of being a,
quote, for hire escort for Ron DeSantis.
MAGA fan Alex Bruesewitz referred to
her as quote Jebba Ellis before going on to
describe her as a quote, D-List reject goon.
So why are all of these hardcore
Trump fans mad at Jenna Ellis
for trying to get a job with Ron DeSantis? Well,
here's what Jenna Ellis had to say about that.
She said, I was called a lot of things and had a
lot of less leftist hit pieces trying to destroy
my credibility while I represented Trump. But I
never saw a media outlet or journo use the blatant
sexism and vulgarity that MAGA influencers do now,
and I don't even work for DeSantis, she added.
So Jenna Ellis, of course, has been the
target of, you know, liberal hit pieces,
as she calls them. There weren't
hit pieces. They were, you know,
talking about your career and the things you were
attempting to do. Now I'm one of those people.
I went after Jenna Ellis plenty because,
of course, she was trying to overturn.
A federal election here in the United
States. That's definitely not something
that lawyers should be doing, especially based on
the fact that all of the evidence was total B.S..
Never wants to launch a sexist attack
against her. Never got vulgar with her.
Just attacked her work, which is fair game.
These attacks are disgusting. I don't care if
Jenna Ellis is working for Donald Trump. I don't
care if she's working for Ron DeSantis. These
attacks are gross and have no place in civilized
discourse here in the United States, especially
when the thing they're accusing her of isn't
even a thing, at least not not as of right now.
So what's happened is these crazed MAGA fans
have created a fantasy in their heads, right?
They have created this scenario where suddenly,
somehow Jenna Ellis works for Ron DeSantis.
And then they got mad about the fantasy
they created and started attacking her for
doing a thing that they think she did. But
she's like, I'm not. I'm not even doing it.
And honestly, who cares if she does? She's
not working for Donald Trump anymore. She
is a free person in this country, allowed to
do whatever the heck she wants to do. If Ron
DeSantis wants to hire her for his campaign as
a legal adviser for a lawyer, he's allowed to
do that. She's allowed to take it. And you don't
get to launch these horrible attacks against her
if you want to go after her record as
a lawyer, if you want to, you know,
critique the things she says when she goes
on, you know, conservative media do it.
But once you start to get into that realm
of these disgusting, horrendous attacks,
that is crossing a line that these
MAGA people seem to love to cross.
Jenna Ellis was once their friend. But again,
because they've created this weird fake scenario,
now they hate her. They're just going to launch
all the horrible attacks they can because they
think she's doing something that would be very
easy to verify if she was doing all right. You
can check the campaign records. You can check
the state records. We do have open records laws,
at least at the moment here in Florida. If she
were working for Ron DeSantis, it would have to
be reported and you could look that up. But that's
a little too much homework for those MAGA folks to
do. So they would rather assume the worst. Which
how is that even the worst? She's not working for
Trump. She's got to work somewhere. He's got to
make money. Right. Republicans always you you got
to have a job. You can't be a lazy mooch. So why
are you begrudging somebody for getting a job?
None of it makes any sense. But then again,
nothing in MAGA world makes any sense